Who's better at cooking,
me or Aaron?
It's me, innit?
Homeboy,
not even a question.
Yo, don't be lying
to the kid, fam.
-He's not in my league.
-Shut up, man.
Modie's gone down,
so I'm running
the fucking mandem now.
What are you gonna do
about the Turks, big man?
I'll chat to the Turks.
-When?
-What the fuck, when?
When I'm fucking ready, fam.
Someone I know,
they have food, innit.
They'll sell to us
way lower than the Turks.
-Boom.
-Sorted.
And you're, what?
Offering to widen
our market?
Yeah. We take your food
and sell it on the road.
That sounds good.
Yeah, we'll take care
of everything.
All you have to do
is sit back
and watch the Ps
come to you.
What Ps?
Money, bruv.
You'll be taking
all the risk as well.
Where I come from,
life is a risk.
You either step up and take
your chances when they come,
if not…
you ain't going nowhere.
Man's got high grade
for sale.
I've got white and B-dose.
What are you saying?
I'm saying,
where you getting this?
That's my business.
Yeah, well, how much?
-White's 40 grand a kilo.
-Forty?
Bruv, allow them prices
there, fam.
You think you're tough
and them tings, brudda?
Can't come to them prices
with bad man, rude boy.
Listen, cut that up.
You're making five times
that much, brudda.
You best be doing
something, man.
A'ight, Jamie is sick.
-Who's that?
-What?
-Oh, shit!
-Fucking hell!
Oh, shit!
Is Cam dead?
No.
So my point is, Jamie,
Cam didn't get your reply.
Jamie, yeah?
The man then can keep doing
what they've always
been doing.
Shot whatever to whoever,
I really don't
give a fuck, bruv.
Just do it on your ends.
And if you need food,
come to me.
So you think I'm here
to get your permission
to shot food?
You're here to get mine.
You want to sell food,
you sell my food,
or you don't sell
nothing at all.
Oh, shit!
Listen, Stef,
nothing bad's ever
gonna happen to you
while I'm around.
I ain't never let you
down before, have I?
Have I?
So I'm gonna do my job
and you do yours.
I am gonna need some of
the Ps you've been making.
In fact, fuck that.
I'm going to need all of
the Ps you've been making.
These are my ends. Mine!
Yeah?
And I'm staying
exactly where I am.
I'm doing it!
-Hands on the wheel!
-Don't shoot!
Remain calm!
Hands down!
Gunshot!
Yo, listen… Modie's dead.
Yeah, we know.
What about
that pussy Jermaine?
We ain't gonna hear
from Jermaine no more.
What happened
to your face, man?
Don't worry about that.
We have one more person
to take care of,
and that's Dushane.
And that needs
to happen today.
Tell A-Road, tell all
of these other crews,
I want everyone,
everywhere looking for him.
D'you understand?
If they see him,
shoot him on sight,
no matter
where the fuck he is.
-So you've got my Ps?
-No.
Your mum got it?
We ain't got nothing.
You'll have to do something
for me then, innit?
Go on. Take that.
Pick up the fucking bag.
Don't fuck this up.
-Armed police!
Firearms.
No, that's… That's not mine.
It was my bag.
You nor Stef nor Abby
had nothing to do with this.
Do you understand?
It's going to be OK, bro.
Judge sees that…
drop the case real quick.
You answer
the next question right,
I'll send it
to your lawyer tonight.
What's the question?
After you get out,
you come and work for me.
Are you being for real?
Yes or no?
Hopefully, this time,
we don't have to make
the same mistake
we made last time,
though, do we?
Yeah, last time was
a little situation still.
I got a link
to Spain and Morocco,
'bout to come through
with a big bit.
More money than you ever
seen in your life, bro.
Do you want to be
a part of it, or what?
Part of it how?
By doing what
you've always done…
selling food.
Your food, yeah?
I guess it is, yeah.
My food.
Why did Ats do that to us?
They had him right
where they wanted,
so he had no choice.
And if the people you love
know you'll be there
for them, no matter what,
then they're gonna be
there for you.
It's like me and Kit.
Something went wrong
and he was there for me
in a heartbeat.
And he knows if
it's the other way around,
it's gonna be
exactly the same.
You get me?
Yeah.
But I was there for Ats.
It was him
that weren't there for me.
If you're close to someone
and they make a mistake,
and they didn't mean to,
or they only done it
because they had to,
then you gotta take that
on board.
Now, don't let hate
eat you up, Stef,
because that ain't good
for no one.
OK?
Give us a hand with this.
Grab the bag.
-Look!
-Fucking hell.
There's a flight tomorrow
morning. I need you on it.
You gotta sort out this shit
in Spain and Morocco for me.
I can't just get up
and leave, fam.
I've got my brothers here.
-I need to be there.
-You stepping up, or what?
Flight's at six.
Someone will meet you there.
Dushane's problem is a guy
called Juan El Bueno.
He's the key.
You make him an offer.
Once Dushane is out of
the way, he'll deal with us.
He'll make a lot of money,
but you and I will make
fucking millions.
You gotta keep your dog
on a short leash.
If you think
they're gonna bite you,
you gotta put them down.
Every top boy needs to know
when to make their move.
So why don't you
give me a number that
I can take back to my boss
and then we'll go
from there?
With this one, it was 10%.
-Nice.
-Yeah.
But now, it's 30.
Thirty percent?
Thirty percent of the value
of each shipment.
You see, right now,
I'm chatting to you
for my boss, yeah?
But there might come
a time real soon
where I'm gonna chat to you
just for me, innit.
So?
So… you get the Duques
to supply me
with everything
that I need in London.
Like I said before, no wars,
just money
and straight business.
What are you doing here,
fam?
I weren't expecting you.
I just came to straighten
a few things out.
I've been patternin' it.
-Oh yeah?
-Yeah.
Twenty-five?
Chief, if you have
something to say, say it,
otherwise move from man,
bro. Big man ting.
Oi…
we're not even doing that.
So, I'm watching you.
You finished, yeah?
Niñato…
you are very quiet tonight.
Last time, you had plenty
to say for yourself.
Big talk and big plans.
Big fucking plans, yeah?
Bro, what you talking about?
-You think I don't know?
-Know what?
You and Juan cosying up.
This one.
Look what we have here.
Yo, what the fuck
are you doing, blud?
What you saying about Jamie?
Look, it looked like one bag
of scheming going on to me.
But you already know
how I feel.
What about the brudda
that killed Ats?
What about him?
We found him.
Yeah, that's
a good thing, right?
Yeah,
you'd think that, innit.
Your boy Kit rubbed him out
before I had a chance
to have a word
and get to the bottom
of exactly why he did it.
Why do you think
he did that?
I don't know.
I weren't there, innit.
Your boy robbed me
of all the answers.
Now, it's over to you
to get them for me.
Don't tell me that you
killed Ats, you know.
Bruv, I didn't!
What happened?
My man was just supposed
to bad him up a likkle,
make him
know himself, innit.
He weren't even supposed
to shank him like that.
Why would you do that?
Bro, what kind of bredren
would I be
knowing what he did to you,
Aaron and Stef
and not do shit about it?
Both of us, fucked.
Kit's gotta go.
What do you mean?
You know
what I fucking mean, man.
If Kit ain't dead
by tomorrow,
then you are.
We've gotta get the fuck
out of here today.
The only thing is where?
Bruv, I've got a cousin
in Cardiff still.
-Yeah?
-So he can…
He can help line us up.
-We have to leave tonight.
-What?
We'll figure our way
around it.
What do you mean
find a way around it?
There's no way around it.
I'm not going.
Aaron, this ain't about you
right now.
Do you hear
what I'm saying to you?
It's about all of us,
making sure
that we're all safe.
Why wouldn't we be safe?
Go on, what did you do?
Yo, where are you going,
Stef, man? Chill.
Hey, Stef, man!
Ay, yo, chill!
What the fuck?
-Let her go!
-Get off me!
-Yo!
-Yo, yo!
Get the fuck off me, man!
Does he know
what he's just fucking done?
Yo! Bruv, what the fuck
are you man doing?
You good, yeah?
-Hey, what the--
-Step the fuck back!
You lot don't want
this smoke,
I fucking told you that.
Stef, don't even worry.
We ain't goin' anywhere.
Everything that I do…
and all that I care about
is the two of you.
You and Stef, that's it.
Cuz, what's with the gloves?
Bro!
See, whatever the beef is
between you two,
what I do believe is Jamie
is our fucking
retirement plan, bro.
It's like you want
to be out here
on the roads in your old age
or something.
I don't.
So that's what it is.
Well, you know what,
maybe you're right.
I think it's time
we moved on.
Jamie!
-Jamie!
Jamie, wake up, please.
Wake up, please.
Jamie, wake up.
Jaime, look at me.
Wake up, please. Jamie!
-Just call the ambulance.
-Jamie, look at me, please.
Jamie, look at me.
-Hello.
-Wake up!